Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. 17th of July, 1796. I write to you, my beloved, very often, and you write very little. You are wicked. You are naughty, oh so naughty, as much as you are fickle. It is unfaithful so to deceive a poor husband, a tender lover. Ought he to lose all his enjoyments, because he is so far away,
感谢收听《历史的余味》。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。1796年7月17日。我亲爱的，我经常写信给你，而你却写得很少。你真是个坏家伙。你很淘气，哦，太淘气了，就像你一样反复无常。欺骗一个可怜的丈夫、一个温柔的情人，是不忠的行为。难道他因为离得太远，
bound down with toil, fatigue, and hardship? Without his Josephine, without the assurance of her love. What has left him upon earth? What can he do? Adieu, adorable Josephine. One of these nights, your door will open with a great noise as a jealous person, and you will find me in your arms. A thousand loving kisses.
被辛劳、疲惫和苦难所束缚，就该失去所有的快乐吗？没有了他的约瑟芬，没有她爱的保证。他在世上还剩下什么？他能做什么？再见，可爱的约瑟芬。总有一天，你的房门会像嫉妒的人那样被猛然推开，你会发现我在你的怀抱中。一千个充满爱意的吻。
Mwah, mwah, mwah. Bonaparte. Oh, God almighty. So, Dominic. I had to watch that. They just have to listen to it. I had to watch that. That was Napoleon Bonaparte writing to Josephine, famous, of course, as his wife, not tonight, Josephine, all that kind of thing, which we will be coming to at the end of this episode. And alert listeners may recall that in the previous episode, I began with a very Ligurian
么么，么么，么么。波拿巴。哦，上帝啊。那么，多米尼克。我不得不看那个。他们必须听听这个。我不得不看那个。那是拿破仑·波拿巴写给约瑟芬的信，当然，她作为他的妻子很有名，不是今晚，约瑟芬，诸如此类的事情，我们将在本集结尾讲到。敏锐的听众可能还记得，在上一集中，我以一种非常利古里亚的
accent. You did. And now I have given Napoleon a French accent, even though actually he never had a French accent. He always kept his course. But you've uncovered a symbolic truth there, Tom, haven't you? It's all about the symbolic truth. It's all about the symbolic truth. Because this episode really is about the process by which Napoleon jettisons his Corsican identity
口音开头。你确实是。现在我给了拿破仑一种法国口音，尽管实际上他从来没有过法国口音。他一直保持着科西嘉口音。但你揭示了一个象征性的真理，汤姆，不是吗？这完全是关于象征性的真理。这完全是关于象征性的真理。因为这一集真正讲述的是拿破仑抛弃他科西嘉身份的过程，
and commits wholeheartedly to La France. Yeah. Is it n'est pas? Yeah, absolutely right. I'm still slightly in shock after that. I mean, it was very Inspector Clouseau, but the stuff with the kisses was quite punchy. I didn't see that coming. Yes. So Napoleon's relationship with Josephine is an intriguing story. Yeah, it's a crazy story, isn't it, actually? So something to look forward to at the end of this episode. But to begin with, Dominic, the revolution is kind of hurtling towards the terror. And meanwhile, Napoleon, having watched the massacres in the Tuileries and all kinds of horrible things, has gone back to Corsica, hasn't he?
并全心全意地投身于法兰西。是的。难道不是吗？是的，完全正确。在那之后我仍然有点震惊。我的意思是，这非常像克鲁索探长，但关于吻的内容相当有力。我没预料到会这样。是的。所以拿破仑与约瑟芬的关系是一个引人入胜的故事。是的，这是一个疯狂的故事，不是吗，实际上？所以本集结尾值得期待。但首先，多米尼克，革命正朝着恐怖时期疾驰而去。与此同时，拿破仑在目睹了杜伊勒里宫的屠杀和各种可怕的事情后，已经回到了科西嘉，不是吗？
He has. So people who listened to episode one will recall that Napoleon, who is, of course, extremely Corsican, speaks to the Corsican accent, has believed himself for a long time to be a kind of son of liberty of Corsica, fighting for an independent Corsica, or it's hard to see what he's fighting for because it's all very confused. He has been going back and forth. And in the autumn of 1792, he has returned to Corsica. France is descending into greater and greater chaos. It is at war with its neighbors who are supporting the king.
是的。所以听过第一集的人会记得，拿破仑，当然，他是极其科西嘉的，说着科西嘉口音，长期以来一直认为自己是科西嘉自由之子，为独立的科西嘉而战，或者很难看出他在为什么而战，因为一切都非常混乱。他一直在来回奔波。1792年秋天，他回到了科西嘉。法国正陷入越来越大的混乱之中。它正在与支持国王的邻国交战。
France is obviously moving towards a republic. It is moving, as you said, towards the terror, the faction fighting in Paris, the Jacobin emerging as the strongest party, the extreme party. And he's back in Corsica, which he discovers in greater chaos than ever. So open faction fighting in the streets. The French have decided to try and invade Sardinia which belongs to their kingdom the neighboring kind of kingdom of um savoy isn't it yeah but the french troops in the harbor when they are out off their ships they kind of roam around causing trouble fighting there are lynchings in the streets um at one point there there's an attack by the French on Corsicans. They mutilate
法国显然正在走向共和国。正如你所说，它正在走向恐怖时期，巴黎的派系斗争，雅各宾派作为最强大的政党、极端政党崛起。而他回到了科西嘉，发现那里比以往任何时候都更加混乱。街头公开的派系斗争。法国人决定尝试入侵撒丁岛，该岛属于他们的邻国萨伏伊王国，不是吗？是的，但当法国军队在港口下船时，他们四处游荡制造麻烦，打架斗殴，街头发生了私刑，嗯，有一次法国人袭击了科西嘉人。他们残害
their bodies and they parade them around the town. At another point, Napoleon himself is captured by some volunteers and some of his men have to rescue him. So it's an incredibly dangerous and anarchic situation. And Dominic, the invasion of Sardinia that you mentioned, this piles disaster on disaster, doesn't it? Because it all goes horribly wrong. And this is Napoleon's first experience of armed combat. And it's an utter humiliation. And he ends up having to spike his own guns and retreat with his tail between his legs. So not a good start. to 10 days and they're beaten off in a very shambolic sort of circumstances they get back to Corsica and everybody says it's everybody else's fault people blame him the big cheese in Corsica Pasquale Paoli who Napoleon had once seen as a kind of father figure has completely turned against the uh the Bonapartes Napoleon's brother Lucien writes a speech denouncing Pauli and sends it to the National Convention in Paris.
他们的尸体，并把它们在镇上游行。另一次，拿破仑本人被一些志愿者俘虏，他的一些手下不得不救他。所以这是一个极其危险和无政府的状态。多米尼克，你提到的入侵撒丁岛，这简直是灾难接踵而至，不是吗？因为它完全搞砸了。这是拿破仑第一次经历武装战斗。这是一场彻底的羞辱。他最终不得不炸毁自己的大炮，夹着尾巴撤退。所以这不是一个好的开始。到10天，他们在非常混乱的情况下被击退，他们回到科西嘉，每个人都说是别人的错，人们指责他，科西嘉的大人物帕斯夸莱·保利，拿破仑曾经把他视为父亲般的人物，已经完全反对波拿巴家族了。拿破仑的兄弟吕西安写了一篇谴责保利的演讲，并将其发送给巴黎的国民公会。
Lucien is very Jacobin, isn't he? He actually changes his name to Brutus, the assassin of Caesar. Yes, exactly. And this is read out. The Bonaparte's denouncing Pauli is read out. That reaches Corsica. And basically in Corsica, it now completely kicks off. Napoleon tries to very
吕西安是非常激进的雅各宾派，不是吗？他实际上把自己的名字改成了布鲁图斯，凯撒的刺客。是的，完全正确。这被宣读了出来。波拿巴家族谴责保利的信被宣读了。这传到了科西嘉。基本上在科西嘉，现在彻底爆发了。拿破仑试图非常
weaselly fashion Tom actually he now tries to write speech himself defending Pauli but basically everybody in the Jacksio is out for his blood there are a whole series of very confused shenanigans which even his biographers say throw their hands up in despair yeah it's impossible to work out what's going on well because this is the Corsican vibe in history, just endless people shooting at each other for reasons that's quite hard to get a handle on. But I think basically, if they don't know themselves, it pays to shoot your neighbour first, right? Because he might shoot you for reasons you don't fully understand.
狡猾地，汤姆，实际上他现在试图自己写演讲稿为保利辩护，但基本上阿雅克肖的所有人都想要他的命，发生了一系列非常混乱的闹剧，连他的传记作者都绝望地摊手，是的，不可能弄清楚发生了什么，因为这就是历史上的科西嘉氛围，无休止的人们因为很难掌握的原因互相射击。但我认为基本上，如果他们自己都不知道，先射击邻居是值得的，对吧？因为他可能会因为你完全不理解的原因射击你。
And this happens to Napoleon. He's arrested. I mean, if I just read you this line, the various accounts of what happened next read like an adventure story with Napoleon arrested, locked up under guard, freed at night by cunning subterfuge, pursued, caught, held with a gun to his temple in the standoff and finally spirited away while rival gangs of bandits settled scores. What is certain is that he was arrested in Boccagno, that he was freed by a cousin, briefly held again and eventually taken to a kinsman shepherd's hut outside of Jaxio. There's this whole series of shenanigans. I think it's pretty obvious to him by this point that basically if he stays in Corsica beyond the spring summer of 1793, he will be killed. His entire family are in fact denounced by an assembly in a place called Corte, which is in the center of the island. They're described as zealous collaborators
这发生在拿破仑身上。他被捕了。我的意思是，如果我读给你听这一行，关于接下来发生的事情的各种描述读起来就像一个冒险故事，拿破仑被捕，被关押在看守下，在夜晚通过狡猾的诡计被释放，被追捕，被抓住，在对峙中被枪指着太阳穴，最后在敌对的匪帮解决恩怨时被悄悄带走。可以肯定的是，他在博卡尼奥被捕，被一个表亲释放，短暂地再次被拘留，最终被带到阿雅克肖外的一个亲戚牧羊人的小屋里。有一连串的闹剧。我认为到目前为止对他来说很明显，基本上如果他在1793年春夏之后留在科西嘉，他就会被杀。他的整个家庭实际上被科尔特的一个议会谴责，科尔特在岛的中心。他们被描述为狂热的合作者，
born in despotism and all this kind of thing. And so basically the entire family have to flee Corsica. Right, and they've been on the island for what, two and a half centuries, I think? Yeah. And they all decide to go and they pile into a boat and set sail for France. And in Abel Gantz's film, have you seen it?
生于专制之中，诸如此类。所以基本上整个家庭都必须逃离科西嘉。对，他们在岛上待了多久，两个半世纪，我想？是的。他们都决定离开，挤进一艘船，启航前往法国。在阿贝尔·冈斯的电影里，你看过吗？
No, never seen it. I've seen clips, but never seen them. I saw it in the South Bank, and there's a brilliant moment at this point. So the Bonapartes are in their boat, sailing from Corsica off to Marseille, and a Royal Navy ship appears. And on board the ship is a young Nelson. No! Brilliant. And he asks
不，从来没看过。我看过片段，但从来没看过全片。我在南岸看过，这一点有一个精彩的时刻。所以波拿巴一家在他们的船上，从科西嘉航行到马赛，一艘皇家海军的船出现了。船上是一个年轻的纳尔逊。不！太棒了。他问
his commanding officer, permission to blow up the ship, sir. And the commanding officer says, no, it will make no difference. Let them go. Oh, no. And Nelson gazes wistfully as Napoleon's ship crashes. Yeah, it's a great moment. How many lives would have been spared if only Nelson had followed his instincts?
他的指挥官，请求炸毁那艘船，长官。指挥官说，不，那不会有任何区别。让他们走吧。哦，不。纳尔逊若有所思地注视着拿破仑的船驶过。是的，这是一个伟大的时刻。如果纳尔逊听从了他的直觉，会有多少生命被挽救？
So the interesting thing about this is that Napoleon only visited Corsica once more in the rest of his life when he was coming back from Egypt in 1799. And he's done with it. He's finished. And actually, after we recorded the previous episode, we were chatting with the producers, weren't we, with Theo and Tabby, about this phenomenon of people who are outsiders taking the reins of kind of expansionist imperialistic nations. So obviously- So Austrians taking... Austrians in Germany, for instance. Have a bad record.
所以关于这一点有趣的是，拿破仑在余生中只再访问过一次科西嘉，那是1799年他从埃及回来的时候。他受够了。他结束了。实际上，在我们录制上一集之后，我们和制片人西奥和塔比聊天，关于这种局外人掌管扩张主义帝国主义国家现象。所以显然——所以奥地利人掌管……例如德国的奥地利人。记录很差。
Georgians in the Soviet Union, for example. And there is definitely... I mean, Napoleon is the great example of this, actually, because he obviously is ultimately Corsican, not French. But there is part of him that feels French as well. And there's also part of him that's turned his back on Corsican and is embarrassed by it, don't you think? Absolutely. But I think that it becomes possible for him ideologically, because as we mentioned in the first episode, the justification for the revolution in France
例如苏联的格鲁吉亚人。这绝对是……我的意思是，拿破仑是这方面伟大的例子，实际上，因为他最终显然是科西嘉人，而不是法国人。但他内心的一部分也感到自己是法国人。而且他内心的一部分也背弃了科西嘉，并为此感到尴尬，你不觉得吗？绝对是。但我认为这在意识形态上对他来说变得可能，因为正如我们在第一集提到的，法国革命的理由
is very, very self-consciously universalist. So by nailing his colours to the French mast, he is also proclaiming himself a would-be citizen of the world. And this, of course, over the long run will provide Napoleon with tremendous justification for all kinds of conquests. Because he's doing it for the good of humanity, not just for France. And I think that that must facilitate psychologically his transition from being Corsican to being French. Don't you think? Oh, I think that's definitely true. The universalism, the invocation of the Romans as forebears, the appeal to kind of republican principles, they allow him to escape the bind, I guess, that he's in to some extent.
是非常、非常自觉的普世主义。所以通过把他的旗帜钉在法国的桅杆上，他也宣称自己是一个未来的世界公民。当然，从长远来看，这将为拿破仑的所有征服提供巨大的理由。因为他是为了人类的利益，而不仅仅是为了法国。我认为这一定在心理上促进了他从科西嘉人到法国人的转变。你不觉得吗？哦，我认为这绝对是真的。普世主义，援引罗马人作为祖先，诉诸共和原则，使他能够在某种程度上逃脱他所处的束缚。
But don't you think psychologically there's also, because he spent so long writing his little histories of Corsica and novels about Corsicans killing loads of Frenchmen and stuff like this. There must have been a little part of him, if only subconsciously, when he puts on the robes of the emperor of the French, when he has all France behind him, that gains this satisfaction. Do you not think from taming the colonial power? Of course, psychologically. He might not have admitted it to himself. Yeah, I'm sure. I'm absolutely sure. But I do also think that the opportunities that revolutionary ideology provides him for self-advancement are incredibly significant. And I think it's really telling that when he gets to France from having escaped from Corsica, that he writes a very, very overtly Jacobin tract, doesn't he? He does.
但你不觉得在心理上也有吗，因为他花了那么长时间写他的科西嘉小历史和关于科西嘉人杀死大量法国人的小说之类的东西。当他穿上法国皇帝的长袍，当他拥有整个法国作为后盾时，他内心深处一定有一小部分，即使只是潜意识里，获得了这种满足感。你不觉得从驯服殖民大国中获得满足吗？当然，在心理上。他可能没有对自己承认。是的，我肯定。我绝对肯定。但我确实也认为革命意识形态为他提供的自我提升机会是非常重要的。而且我认为非常能说明问题的是，当他从科西嘉逃出来到达法国时，他写了一篇非常、非常公开的雅各宾派文章，不是吗？他确实写了。
And has it kind of published, very much saying, this is what I am. I am now a French Jacobin. Yeah, he does. Le Soupé de Boucère, it's called, a kind of weird sort of polemic disguised as conversation among people at an inn in Boucère, which is between Avignon and Nice. I mean, it's a pure political manifesto, really. Adam Zmoyski is very good on this in his book, talking about how this is the moment where you see in this manifesto, very much in keeping, I think, with the mood of the times, which is war-torn, you know, the revolution is clearly, we're moving into the terror.
并把它出版了，很大程度上说，这就是我。我现在是一个法国雅各宾派。是的，他写了。《博凯尔的晚餐》，它被称为，一种伪装成博凯尔一家旅馆里人们谈话的奇怪的辩论。博凯尔在阿维尼翁和尼斯之间。我的意思是，这纯粹是一份政治宣言，真的。亚当·扎莫伊斯基在他的书中对此写得很好，谈到这是你在这份宣言中看到的时刻，非常符合时代的情绪，即饱受战争蹂躏，你知道，革命显然，我们正在进入恐怖时期。
There's a kind of grim cynicism to it, a sort of fear of the excesses of human nature, an emphasis on strong government, on shedding blood, on all these kinds of things, which is very of the moment. We talked about his adolescent histrionics, this tone that runs throughout his writings from his teenage years. But by the time he's getting into his late 20s and the events around him and he is starting to become a player in it, a tone that sounds histrionic when you're a 16-year-old increasingly comes to match the circumstances that he finds himself in. Well, because the people who are running the revolution are now the people who are 16-year-olds at the same time as him, right? Yeah. The Saint-Justs, I mean, even the other people on the Committee of Public Safety,
有一种冷酷的犬儒主义，一种对人性过激行为的恐惧，一种对强力政府、流血、所有这些事情的强调，这非常符合当时的情况。我们谈到了他青春期的表演欲，这种语气贯穿了他从十几岁开始的著作。但当他进入20多岁，周围发生的事情，他开始成为其中的参与者时，当你是16岁时听起来像表演的语气，越来越符合他所处的环境。嗯，因为运行革命的人现在是和他同时代16岁的人，对吧？是的。圣茹斯特，我的意思是，即使是公共安全委员会的其他成员，
they're remarkably young. They're all tanked up. Remember we talked about this when we did that French Revolution podcast back in the midst of time. Their wine bills are through the roof. They've been probably talking about the purifying nature of bloodshed for years anyway, and now they have a chance to put it into practice. For Napoleon, it's different because he's not in Paris. He remains an army officer. He remains an artillery commander. And with the escalation of the terror, so also France is becoming internationally ever more besieged. So that Royal Navy ship in the Able Gantsville with Nelson on it is an expression of the fact that Britain and France by this point are at war. And there are Aristo's reactionary pro-royalist French forces that are now in alliance with the Royal Navy. And they are looking to seize a port on the south coast, aren't they? Basically, when he gets back to France, France is a war zone.
他们非常年轻。他们都喝醉了。记得我们在很久以前做那个法国大革命播客时谈过这个吗。他们的酒单高得离谱。他们可能多年来一直在谈论流血的净化本质，现在他们有机会将其付诸实践。对拿破仑来说，这不同，因为他不在巴黎。他仍然是一名陆军军官。他仍然是一名炮兵指挥官。随着恐怖时期的升级，法国在国际上也越来越被围困。所以阿贝尔·冈斯电影里那艘有纳尔逊的皇家海军船，是英国和法国此时处于战争状态的事实的一种表达。而且有反动的亲保皇党法国势力现在与皇家海军结盟。他们正试图夺取南海岸的一个港口，不是吗？基本上，当他回到法国时，法国是一个战区。
South of France is a war zone. Ten provinces have turned against the national convention. There's a full-scale revolution against the revolution in the Vendée and the west of France. Counter-revolution, I believe is the phrase, Dominique. Yes. Thank you. I was looking for that. I like revolution against the revolution.
法国南部是一个战区。十个省份已经背叛了国民公会。在旺代和法国西部，有一场针对革命的全面革命。反革命，我相信是这个词，多米尼克。是的。谢谢。我一直在找这个词。我喜欢“针对革命的革命”。
I think that's a more French-free way of putting it. La révolution contre la révolution, Tom. Peut-être. If I was a polo-neck-wearing French professor, that's what I'd call it. That'd be the title of my book, my monograph. Anyway, Royalists had taken Toulon, and they had occupied it in collaboration with the British, with a fleet under Admiral Hood. Which has sailed in, hasn't it?
我认为这是一种更不带法国色彩的说法。针对革命的革命，汤姆。也许吧。如果我是一个穿高领毛衣的法国教授，那这就是我会叫它的名字。那将是我书的标题，我的专著。总之，保皇党占领了土伦，他们与英国人合作占领了它，舰队由胡德海军上将指挥。他已经航行进来了，不是吗？
Yes. And seized control of all the naval dockyards. Because we talked about this in the context of the episodes we did on Nelson, that navies cannot function without well-stocked dockyards. I know you love a dockyard. So by seizing Toulon, the British have effectively knocked out the French navy. So the convention have sent an army to recapture Toulon, and Bonaparte ends up being associated with this army as an artillery officer. And the guy who is in charge of the artillery is badly wounded in the early sort of engagements around Toulon, and Napoleon ends up being promoted to replace him. I mean, it's a really interesting thing
是的。并夺取了所有海军造船厂的控制权。因为我们在谈论纳尔逊的剧集中谈到过这一点，海军没有库存充足的造船厂就无法运作。我知道你喜欢造船厂。所以通过占领土伦，英国人有效地击垮了法国海军。所以公会派了一支军队去夺回土伦，波拿巴最终作为一名炮兵军官与这支军队联系在一起。负责炮兵的人在土伦周围的早期交战中受了重伤，拿破仑最终被提升以取代他。我的意思是，这是一件非常有趣的事情，
that's happening because you've said a couple of times about the revolution clearing the way for Napoleon. That's obviously what this does, because people who are very young are being thrust into positions, as in Paris, of unexpected power and responsibility because their elders have either defected to the other side or are leading the rebellion or have been executed. So Napoleon is the next guy in line. And actually, some people say, really? I mean, he's never really done anything. He's just a kid. And somebody says they've read his Jacobin pamphlet, Le Super de Bocaire, and they say, well, he's one of us. Very kind of Thatcherite approach. He's on, you know, he's ideologically, he's okay.
正在发生，因为你已经好几次说革命为拿破仑扫清了道路。这显然就是它所做的，因为非常年轻的人被推到了意想不到的权力和责任位置上，就像在巴黎一样，因为他们的长辈要么投奔了另一方，要么领导了叛乱，要么被处决了。所以拿破仑是下一个排队的人。实际上，有些人说，真的吗？我的意思是，他从来没做过什么。他只是个孩子。有人说他们读过他的雅各宾派小册子《博凯尔的晚餐》，他们说，嗯，他是我们的一员。非常撒切尔式的做法。他在，你知道，他在意识形态上，他没问题。
He's on side. He's on side. And actually, some people may say who love Napoleon, because of course, there are always people who adore Napoleon. Andrew Roberts, for example. They may say, Tom and Dominic have been very sniffy about Napoleon in these podcasts. But actually, he really distinguishes himself at Toulon, doesn't he?
他在一边。他在一边。实际上，有些人可能会说，那些热爱拿破仑的人，因为当然，总有人崇拜拿破仑。例如安德鲁·罗伯茨。他们可能会说，汤姆和多米尼克在这些播客中对拿破仑非常挑剔。但实际上，他在土伦确实表现出色，不是吗？
Oh, he does tremendously well, doesn't he? And he does it in all kinds of ways. So his strategic sense, there are heights commanding the harbour. And even though the French don't have ships with which to attack the Royal Navy, Napoleon immediately recognises that if they can seize the forts that the British and the Royalists. Napoleon immediately recognises that if they can seize the forts that the British and the Royalists have occupied, then this will be tremendous, because the Royal Navy will have no choice but to retreat. Napoleon immediately recognises that. He recognises that to make this happen, he will need to source large quantities of artillery. And so he never rests. He gets artillery from every corner of Southern France that he can, concentrating an immense quantity of firepower. And also, he is physically very brave. I mean,
哦，他表现得非常出色，不是吗？他以各种方式做到了。所以他的战略感，有指挥港口的高地。即使法国人没有船只来攻击皇家海军，拿破仑也立即认识到，如果他们能夺取英国人和保皇党占领的堡垒，那么这将是巨大的，因为皇家海军将别无选择，只能撤退。拿破仑立即认识到了这一点。他认识到要实现这一点，他需要获取大量的炮兵。所以他从不休息。他从法国南部的每一个角落获取炮兵，集中了巨大的火力。而且，他在身体上也非常勇敢。我的意思是，
he's absolutely in the heart of the fighting. And at one point, an artilleryman is killed. There's great explosions going on. Napoleon se seizes his gloves loads of cannon fires it himself and uh it's all tremendous and the cost that napoleon pays for doing this dominic is that he gets scabies from the gloves that's right yes yes scabies i mean he gets it for about the next 10 years he does and so this is an important part of his courtship of josephine which will come to you later would you like to come up upstairs and look at my scabies he's not only kind of scrawny and unsophisticated but he's got scabies so yes you know but we all have to make sacrifices for la patrie we do right exactly that's napoleon's sacrifice so he really impresses his superior officers the army attacking too long
他绝对处于战斗的核心。有一次，一名炮兵被杀。到处都是巨大的爆炸。拿破仑抓起他的手套，自己装填大炮并开火，这太棒了。拿破仑为此付出的代价，多米尼克，是他从手套里感染了疥疮。没错，是的，是的，疥疮。我的意思是，他感染了大约10年。他确实感染了，所以这是他追求约瑟芬的重要部分，我们稍后会讲到。你想上楼看看我的疥疮吗？他不仅瘦骨嶙峋、不谙世事，而且还得了疥疮。所以是的，你知道，但我们都必须为祖国做出牺牲。我们确实做到了，对吧，完全正确，那是拿破仑的牺牲。所以他确实给他的高级军官留下了深刻印象。攻击土伦的军队
goes through a succession of different generals many of whom are utterly useless they're kind of doctors people who write poems yeah this kind of thing but they almost without exception recognize napoleon that he's a very charismatic leader that his attention to detail his work ethic his seriousness really impresses his men. He's getting fans, not just senior people, but also there's a guy called Junot, who will end up becoming one of his great generals. A guy called Marmont, another one of his great kind of collaborators. And also there's a man called Augustin Robespierre, who is the brother of the big Gs in Paris. And obviously an alliance with a Robespierre. Very good, isn't it? Yeah. Well, as long as the Robespierres can stay in power and obviously an alliance with a Robespierre. Very good, isn't it?
经历了一连串不同的将军，其中许多人完全没用。他们是医生，写诗的人，诸如此类。但他们几乎无一例外地认可拿破仑，他是一位非常有魅力的领导者，他对细节的关注、他的职业道德、他的严肃性确实给他的手下留下了深刻印象。他有了粉丝，不仅是高级人员，还有一个叫朱诺的人，他最终将成为他伟大的将军之一。一个叫马尔蒙的人，他另一个伟大的合作者。还有一个叫奥古斯丁·罗伯斯庇尔的人，他是巴黎大人物的兄弟。显然与罗伯斯庇尔结盟。非常好，不是吗？是的。只要罗伯斯庇尔家族能掌权，显然与罗伯斯庇尔结盟。非常好，不是吗？
Yeah. Well, as long as the Robespierres can stay in power and not shoot their jaws off and end up on the guillotine. Of course. But I mean, the thing is that taking the war to the British is obviously a way to win the hearts of pretty much everyone in France. Yeah. To a degree, even royalists in their hearts are going to be conflicted at a French victory
是的。只要罗伯斯庇尔家族能掌权，不把自己的下巴打掉，最终走上断头台。当然。但我的意思是，对英国人发动战争显然是赢得法国几乎所有人心的好方法。是的。在某种程度上，即使是保皇党在内心深处也会对法国在英国武装面前的胜利感到矛盾。
over British arms. And so Napoleon does very well on this score. And he even captures a British commander of one of the forts above Toulon, a guy called Charles O'Hara. He'd been launching a counterattacking sally against the besieging French, gets captured. And this was the same guy, Dominic, who had surrendered on behalf of General Cornwallis at Yorktown to George Washington. And now he surrenders to Napoleon. So he's the only person ever personally
所以拿破仑在这方面做得很好。他甚至俘虏了土伦上方堡垒的一名英国指挥官，一个叫查尔斯·奥哈拉的人。他一直在对围城的法国人发动反击突袭，结果被俘。这就是同一个人，多米尼克，他曾代表康沃利斯将军在约克镇向乔治·华盛顿投降。现在他向拿破仑投降了。所以他是唯一一个亲自
to have surrendered to both Washington and Napoleon. And he gets sent off to Paris where he ends up in prison with Thomas Paine. The rights of man by this point has been imprisoned. And apparently gets on tremendously well with him. Oh, I think worse and worse of him tom golly what a record yeah what a record odd that we don't make more of uh general o'hara in prison yes um so um the defeat of general o'hara i mean that's very helpful and by december 1793 essentially napoleon strategy has worked yes the commanding heights have been seized and Admiral Hood has no choice but to beat retreat. And there are a lot of explosions going on, aren't there? Huge, huge excitement.
向华盛顿和拿破仑投降的人。他被送往巴黎，最终与托马斯·潘恩一起被关进监狱。《人的权利》的作者此时已被监禁。显然和他相处得非常好。哦，我越来越看不起他了，汤姆，天哪，什么记录，是的，什么记录，奇怪的是我们没有更多地谈论奥哈拉将军在监狱里的事，是的，嗯，所以，奥哈拉将军的失败，我的意思是，这非常有帮助，到1793年12月，拿破仑的战略基本上奏效了，是的，指挥高地已被夺取，胡德海军上将别无选择，只能撤退。到处都是爆炸，不是吗？巨大，巨大的兴奋。
And Napoleon will always remember with a kind of, you know, the thrill of watching magazines and ships exploding. So later in life, he remembered the whirlwind of flames and smoke from the arsenal resembled the eruption of a volcano and the 13 vessels blazing in the roads were like so many displays of fireworks. The masts and forms of the vessels were distinctly traced out by the flames, which lasted many hours and formed an unparalleled spectacle. So the thrill of violence, war, and victory, I guess. Very suitable background for the spectacular achievements of this upstart young officer.
拿破仑总是会带着一种，你知道，观看弹药库和船只爆炸的快感回忆起这件事。所以晚年，他回忆起军火库中火焰和烟雾的旋风，就像火山喷发，在航道上燃烧的13艘船只就像无数的烟花表演。船只的桅杆和形状被火焰清晰地勾勒出来，火焰持续了许多小时，形成了无与伦比的奇观。所以暴力、战争和胜利的快感，我想。非常适合这位暴发户年轻军官的壮观成就的背景。
He did very well at Toulon. Everybody recognizes that he's the architect of victory. It's not just that he planned the strategy to seize the forts rather than the city. In other words, to remove the British Navy as a factor, which basically means the city has no choice but to fall. But also, he led them in. and removed the British Navy as a factor, which basically means the city has no choice but to fall. But also, he led them in. I mean, he led his men, you know, saber drawn kind of thing. He received a big wound, didn't he, to the leg.
他在土伦表现得非常好。每个人都承认他是胜利的建筑师。这不仅仅是因为他计划了夺取堡垒而不是城市的战略。换句话说，消除英国海军作为一个因素，这基本上意味着城市别无选择，只能陷落。而且他还带领他们冲了进去。并消除了英国海军作为一个因素，这基本上意味着城市别无选择，只能陷落。而且他还带领他们冲了进去。我的意思是，他带领他的手下，你知道，拔出军刀之类的。他受了重伤，不是吗，腿部。
Yes, from a British officer, from a bayonet. It's a perfect wound because you're not going to die. But you get a scar. But you get a scar and everybody will say he led his troops. He led them in, sword in hand in hand he was wounded what a hero actually the siege of toulon what something that doesn't often get brought out i don't know whether ridley scott's film will bring it out is what happened next to toulon so the people of toulon were desperate to get away they were throwing themselves it's very kind of smyrna 1920s they're're throwing themselves into the sea, desperate to reach the British ships.
是的，被一名英国军官用刺刀刺伤。这是一个完美的伤口，因为你不会死。但你会留下伤疤。但你会留下伤疤，每个人都会说他带领了他的部队。他带领他们冲了进去，手持利剑，他受伤了，真是个英雄。实际上，土伦围城战，有些事情不常被提起，我不知道雷德利·斯科特的电影会不会提出来，那就是土伦接下来发生了什么。所以土伦的人民拼命想逃走，他们把自己扔进海里，这非常像1920年代的士麦那，他们拼命想到达英国船只。
Probably thousands of people were raped and killed and mutilated in various ways. Yeah, because I think the population was something like 25,000. By the end of it, it's about 7,000. I mean, that's a lot of people killed. Because the Revolutionary Army, once they got into Toulon, the commanders just said, right, go for it. You've got three days. Do what you like. I mean, this is at the same time as that campaign in the Vendée, which some historians have characterized as near genocidal, just wiping out.
可能有成千上万的人被强奸、杀害和以各种方式残害。是的，因为我认为人口大约是25,000人。到最后，大约剩下7,000人。我的意思是，很多人被杀了。因为革命军，一旦他们进入土伦，指挥官们就说，好吧，去吧。你们有三天时间。做你们想做的事。我的意思是，这与旺代的那场运动同时发生，一些历史学家将其描述为近乎种族灭绝，只是消灭。
People being put in cages and chucked in the loire and all kinds of things. Exactly. Napoleon said later that he was revolted by it, that he was shocked at the atrocities. I think whether it's the violence that shocks him or whether it's the spectacle of disorder that shocks him, it's hard to say. Probably the latter, I would suggest. Because as we talked last time, he hates the idea of any form of anarchy, of any confusion or chaos, I suppose partly because of what he's seen on Corsica. But he comes out of Toulon,
人们被关进笼子里扔进卢瓦尔河，诸如此类。正是如此。拿破仑后来表示他对此感到反感，他对暴行感到震惊。我认为是暴力让他震惊，还是混乱的景象让他震惊，很难说。我建议可能是后者。因为正如我们上次谈到的，他讨厌任何形式的无政府状态，任何混乱或混乱，我想部分是因为他在科西嘉看到的。但他从土伦出来，
everything's looking great. He is promoted to brigadier general, a general at 24. Extraordinary. There's talk of him joining the army of Italy that will push into Piedmont. He's drawing up plans for that. He has a great scheme that he will go through Italy and get to Vienna and knock Austria out of the war. And his great pal that he has made in the siege of Toulon, Augustin Robespierre, obviously a coming man, the brother of Maximilian.in Robespierre, obviously a coming man, the brother of Maximilian. And Robespierre says to him, why don't I take you with me to Paris?
一切看起来都很棒。他被提升为准将，24岁的将军。非凡。有传言说他要加入将推进到皮埃蒙特的意大利军团。他正在为此制定计划。他有一个伟大的计划，他将穿过意大利到达维也纳，把奥地利踢出战争。他在土伦围城战中结交的好朋友，奥古斯丁·罗伯斯庇尔，显然是一个前途无量的人，马克西米连的兄弟。显然是一个前途无量的人，马克西米连的兄弟。罗伯斯庇尔对他说，为什么我不带你和我一起去巴黎？
What could possibly go wrong? And going to Paris in 1794 with a Robespierre. So this is a really interesting road not taken because some people have said, maybe he would have ended up commanding the National Guard in Paris in mid 1794. And had he done that, had he gone with Augustin to Paris, I guess he might have been executed at Termidor in the turn against the Jacobin. I'd have thought it very, very likely. He'd be a threat, wouldn't he? He would. A successful military man who had pinned his colors so firmly to the Rosé Pierre mast.
什么可能出错呢？1794年带着一个罗伯斯庇尔去巴黎。所以这是一条非常有趣的未走之路，因为有些人说，也许他最终会在1794年中期指挥巴黎的国民自卫军。如果他那样做了，如果他跟着奥古斯丁去了巴黎，我想他可能在热月政变中被处决了。我想这非常、非常可能。他会是一个威胁，不是吗？他会是。一个成功的军事人物，把他的旗帜如此坚定地钉在罗伯斯庇尔的桅杆上。
So he doesn't go. He's still in the south of France at Nice at the beginning of August 1794, when he gets news that his great pal has been guillotined. There's been a turn against the extremists on the Committee of Public Safety. There's been a coup in Paris, the Termidor coup. And he's actually briefly arrested. I don't't there's ever a serious threat to him but he's briefly detained because isn't it juno proposes trying to break him out he does exactly and says no don't do that it'll be fine it'll be fine and it is fine but obviously what he needs now is a new focus and um he needs a kind of new patron i suppose and in the second half
所以他没去。1794年8月初，当他得知他的好朋友被送上断头台时，他还在法国南部的尼斯。公共安全委员会的极端分子发生了反转。巴黎发生了政变，热月政变。他实际上被短暂逮捕了。我不认为这对他构成严重威胁，但他被短暂拘留了，因为朱诺不是提议试图把他救出来吗？他确实这样做了，并说不，别那样做，会没事的，会没事的，确实没事。但显然他现在需要一个新的焦点，嗯，他需要一个新的赞助人，我想，在下半部分
we'll see how he finds this new patron a man called paul barras who as luck would have it is going to become the single most influential figure in the new regime the directory he will be requiring from napoleon a whiff of grapeshot. And crucially, Tom, which will give you a chance to delve back into that lovely impression, Barras has a girlfriend called Josephine. So we'll be meeting her after the break. The whiff of grapeshot. Won't be the only whiff, but more on that later.
我们将看到他是如何找到这个新赞助人的，一个叫保罗·巴拉斯的人，正如运气所愿，他将成为新政权督政府中最具影响力的人物，他将要求拿破仑提供“一抹葡萄弹”。而且至关重要的是，汤姆，这将给你一个机会深入研究那个可爱的模仿，巴拉斯有一个女朋友叫约瑟芬。所以我们将在休息后见到她。一抹葡萄弹。不会是唯一的味道，但稍后会有更多关于这个的内容。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. But more on that later. episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest is entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com welcome back to the rest is history we are still dealing with the young napoleon so napoleon has lost a potential patron in his friend augustin robespierre the termidorian reaction in par Paris is underway. So that's a turn against the kind of what are perceived as being the kind of militant excesses of the terror. He doesn't initially go to Paris, does he, Tom? He spends a lot of time lurking around the south of France, where he actually ends up getting engaged, Napoleon. He does, yes, to Eugène-Désiré Clary, who is very sweet. Napoleon, I mean, he's not the greatest romantic figure, is he? Basically, he just kind of mansplains to her what she should be reading and bullies her
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》。但稍后会有更多内容。剧集和抢先观看现场门票，请前往 the rest is entertainment.com，网址是 the rest is entertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余味》，我们仍在处理年轻的拿破仑。所以拿破仑在他的朋友奥古斯丁·罗伯斯庇尔身上失去了一个潜在的赞助人，巴黎的热月党人反应正在进行中。所以那是对被视为恐怖时期激进过激行为的一种反转。他最初没有去巴黎，是吗，汤姆？他花了很多时间在法国南部潜伏，在那里他实际上最终订婚了，拿破仑。他确实订婚了，对象是尤金-德西雷·克拉里，她非常甜美。拿破仑，我的意思是，他不是最伟大的浪漫人物，是吗？基本上，他只是向她解释她应该读什么，并欺负她，
because she doesn't play the piano well enough and all kinds of things. Kind of nightmare boyfriend. He's about 10 years older than her, isn't he? Just under 10 years, because she's about 16. And he's constantly writing her letters saying, You don't want to do it like that yeah are you doing your music practice your music teacher is awful i think you should be playing this and all this kind of thing that's how you do it i'll show you yeah amazingly she she tolerates all this it seems to be a great romance doesn't she actually you see she ends up as the queen of sweden yeah she marries bernadotte doesn't
因为她钢琴弹得不够好，诸如此类。某种噩梦般的男朋友。他比她大10岁左右，不是吗？不到10岁，因为她大约16岁。他不断地给她写信说，你不想那样做，是的，你在练习音乐吗？你的音乐老师太糟糕了，我认为你应该弹这个，诸如此类，这就是你应该做的方式，我会展示给你看，是的，令人惊讶的是，她容忍了所有这些，这似乎是一段伟大的浪漫，不是吗？实际上，你看她最终成为了瑞典王后，是的，她嫁给了贝尔纳多特，不是吗？
she does yeah who become she has a very impressive life yeah so her descendant is i mean that it's still on the swedish throne to this day i think exactly she's the winner of all this she's the real star of this of this series anyway he's he's kind of carrying on with her bossing around and stuff he goes off to paris with juno and marmont who are kind of hero worshipping him by this point first of all when he gets to paris it's a very strange atmosphere in Paris, isn't it? Because they're still at war, but there's been a sort of backlash against the whole terror thing. So now there's this sort of Weimar Republic. Yeah, so everyone is partying, celebrations, orgies.
她确实嫁了，是的，他成为了，她有一个非常令人印象深刻的生活，是的，所以她的后代是，我的意思是，直到今天仍然在瑞典王位上，我想，完全正确，她是这一切的赢家，她是这个系列真正的明星。总之，他带着她到处指手画脚，他和朱诺和马尔蒙一起去了巴黎，他们此时对他顶礼膜拜。首先，当他到达巴黎时，巴黎的气氛非常奇怪，不是吗？因为他们仍在战争中，但对整个恐怖时期有一种反弹。所以现在有这种魏玛共和国。是的，所以每个人都在聚会、庆祝、狂欢。
Yeah, sort of sex and money everywhere. Yeah. But people are kind of doing things like, I've seen, I was astounded by this. The weird ball for people whose relatives have been guillotined. Did you see that? Balls for people
是的，到处都是性和金钱。是的。但人们正在做一些事情，比如，我看到了，我对此感到震惊。为亲属被送上断头台的人举办的怪异舞会。你看到了吗？为亲属
whose relatives have been guillotined. And you wear a thin red stripe around your neck. They have parties in the prisons where the September massacres had happened where you wear,
被送上断头台的人举办的舞会。你脖子上戴着一条细红条纹。他们在发生九月大屠杀的监狱里举办派对，在那里你戴着，
yeah, where you wear a red ribbon around your neck. Yeah. Like you've been guillotined. I mean, that is bonkers. But he,
是的，在那里你脖子上戴着一条红丝带。是的。就像你被送上断头台一样。我的意思是，那太疯狂了。但他，
when he goes to these parties, he's very shifty, awkward. It's not his scene, is it? No. You can take the boy out of Corsica, but... You can't take... they're all Corsican, shifty, and awkward at parties. No, but they're not having kind of decadent type parties with... No, they're not. You know, relatives of guillotine duchesses in a jacksio, are they? I mean, that's the
当他去这些派对时，他非常狡猾、尴尬。这不是他的场景，是吗？不。你可以把男孩带出科西嘉，但……你不能带走……他们都是科西嘉人，狡猾且在派对上尴尬。不，但他们没有那种颓废类型的派对……不，他们没有。你知道，在阿雅克肖的断头台公爵夫人的亲戚，是吗？我的意思是，那是
whole point of it. They're wearing wide trousers and shooting pistols at each other. Wide trousers and eating goat's cheese. Yeah. Growing big moustaches. It's a very different party vibe, Dominic. I'm not saying which one is better. No.
它的全部意义。他们穿着宽大的裤子，互相射击手枪。宽大的裤子和吃山羊奶酪。是的。留着大胡子。这是一个非常不同的派对氛围，多米尼克。我不是说哪一个更好。不。
I'm not being judgmental. I'm just saying you can understand. It must be awkward for a young lad from Ajaxio. It's the difference between South London and Chipping Norton, Tom. That that's pretty much what it is i thought you were going to say the difference between south london and mayfair no i wasn't oh you're casting the south londoners as the corsicans yes okay while he's hanging around in paris he becomes friendly with this guy who's an extraordinary character called paul barras and barras had been at toulon as a kind of political bigwig attached to the
我不是在评判。我只是说你可以理解。对于一个来自阿雅克肖的年轻小伙子来说，这一定很尴尬。这是南伦敦和奇平诺顿的区别，汤姆。这基本上就是它，我以为你要说南伦敦和梅菲尔的区别，不，我不是，哦，你把南伦敦人当作科西嘉人了，是的，好吧，当他在巴黎闲逛时，他与这个家伙变得友好，他是一个非凡的人物，叫保罗·巴拉斯，巴拉斯曾在土伦作为一种政治大人物附属于
army. Barras had an extraordinary history. He'd fought the British in India. He'd then become a sort of delegate at the convention. He'd played a small kind of supporting part in the downfall of Robespierre. And he had worked his way up to become the chief figure in this new regime, which is known as the Directory. And Barras is incredibly corrupt, conniving, kind of cynical, doesn't trust anybody, nobody trusts him. But he is incredibly rich. He's basically siphoning a lot of the money that goes to the army for himself. And he knows everybody. Paris is full of his ex-lovers and his friends and all of this sort of thing. And he is a very useful person for Napoleon to know.
军队。巴拉斯有一段非凡的历史。他在印度与英国人作战。他后来成为公会的一名代表。他在罗伯斯庇尔的垮台中扮演了一个小的支持角色。他一路晋升，成为这个被称为督政府的新政权的主要人物。巴拉斯极其腐败、勾结、犬儒，不信任任何人，没人信任他。但他极其富有。他基本上把很多给军队的钱挪为己用。而且他认识所有人。巴黎到处都是他的前情人、朋友和所有这些东西。对于拿破仑来说，他是一个非常有用的认识的人。
But at first, it's not clear what's going to happen to Napoleon. Technically, he's been posted to the Vendée, to this incredibly brutal campaign. But he doesn't want to go, does he? He doesn't want to go. He doesn't want to go and fight fellow Frenchmen, which is interesting. He spends a lot of time in very Napoleon style, writing a novel. So he writes a sort of romantic novel, doesn't he? It's about a young lad, very brave. I mean, who it could be modelled on, God only knows. But isn't he also at the same time as
但起初，拿破仑会发生什么并不清楚。从技术上讲，他被派往旺代，参加那场极其残酷的运动。但他不想去，是吗？他不想去。他不想去和法国同胞作战，这很有趣。他花了很多时间，以非常拿破仑的风格，写一部小说。所以他写了一部浪漫小说，不是吗？它是关于一个年轻小伙子，非常勇敢。我的意思是，他可能是以谁为原型，天知道。但他不是同时也在
he's writing his novel, contemplating perhaps going to Constantinople, perhaps even going to India and joining the East India Company? I mean, kind of history would have been very different then, wouldn't it? So he's a bit mopey because I'd always had the vague sense that, you know, he becomes the great star after too long. But actually, he's kind of slightly stuck, isn't he? He's treading water. Yeah, he is. Exactly.
他当时正在写小说，或许在考虑去君士坦丁堡，甚至去印度加入东印度公司？我的意思是，如果那样的话，历史将会大不相同，不是吗？所以他有点郁闷，因为我一直有一种模糊的感觉，你知道，他过不了多久就会成为大明星。但实际上，他当时有点被困住了，不是吗？他在原地踏步。是的，确实如此。没错。
I thought the same. I thought he would have been taken up as the great hero. But not really. He's just sort of drifting. And then fate really plays into his hands. Because in the summer of 1795 paris we're talking about france but it's really paris is in a very uncertain position because they they need to adopt a new constitution and it's not clear whether the new
我也这么想。我以为他会被当作大英雄接纳。但并没有。他只是在随波逐流。然后命运真的眷顾了他。因为在1795年的夏天，巴黎——我们谈论的是法国，但实际上是巴黎——处于一个非常不确定的境地，因为他们需要通过一部新宪法，而且不清楚这部新
constitution will be more left wing or right wing than the republican constitution under the jacobin and what is more there has there is clearly a lot of latent royalist support right so louis the 16th has been executed and his son the poor boy who gets put in a cage doesn't he pretty much and yeah i mean horrible um and he dies which means that the enormously fat new king is louisIII, who is obviously not in France. He's in Italy, I think. But he's siding with all the... Well, he'll end up in Britain, do you call it, 20? Yeah.
宪法会比雅各宾派统治下的共和宪法更偏左还是更偏右，而且更重要的是，显然存在大量潜在的保皇党支持者，对吧？路易十六已经被处决了，他的儿子，那个可怜的孩子，被关进了笼子里，不是吗？真的，我的意思是太可怕了，嗯，他死了，这意味着那个极其肥胖的新国王是路易十八，他显然不在法国。我想他在意大利。但他站在所有……好吧，他最终会去英国，你说是20岁吗？是的。
But it's that kind of royalist, internationalist axis. But therefore, the realisation that there are lots of potential royalists in Paris is very unsettling for anyone concerned with the survival of the Republic. Yes, exactly. So we're approaching the month of... Well, we concerned with the survival of the Republic. Yes, exactly. So we're approaching the month of, well, we're in the month of Vendée Mière because they're still using the mad revolutionary calendar. Yeah. But on what we would call the evening of the 3rd of October, 1795, Napoleon gets a message
但这就是那种保皇派的国际轴心。因此，意识到巴黎有许多潜在的保皇党人，这对任何关心共和国生存的人来说都是非常令人不安的。是的，完全正确。所以我们正在接近……好吧，我们关心共和国的生存。是的，完全正确。所以我们正在接近，嗯，我们正处于葡月，因为他们还在使用那个疯狂的革命历。是的。但在我们所说的1795年10月3日晚上，拿破仑收到了一条消息
from Paul Barras. Now, Paul Barras is a member of the Committee of Public Safety. He's the kind of the real, I wouldn't say the guiding spirit, but he's one of the most influential people in the directory. And Barras says, come to my house at Chaillot, which is to the kind of west of Paris. I need to talk to you. So the next morning, Bonaparte goes along.
来自保罗·巴拉斯。现在，保罗·巴拉斯是公安委员会的一员。他算是真正的——我不会说是指导精神，但他是在督政府中最有影响力的人之一。巴拉斯说，到我位于夏约的家里来，那是在巴黎的西边。我需要和你谈谈。所以第二天早上，波拿巴就去了。
It's the morning of the 4th. And Barras says to him, there are things that need to be done in Paris. There are royalists. There's trouble coming. I need to know that I can rely on you. And Bonaparte clearly says to him, okay, fine. You can rely on me. He goes back to Paris.
那是4号的早上。巴拉斯对他说，巴黎有些事情需要处理。有保皇党人。麻烦要来了。我需要知道我能依靠你。波拿巴明确地对他说，好的，没问题。你可以依靠我。他回到了巴黎。
Then he goes to the theater. People are always doing that in the French Revolution, aren't they? Of course. Crucial moments. Yeah. They're in the middle of a massive coup, and they say well hold on there's a i don't want to miss that so he goes to the to the theater and when he gets out he hears that one of the sections le pelletier which is in the center of paris has revolted so the sections are the kind
然后他去了剧院。人们在法国大革命期间总是这样做，不是吗？当然。关键时刻。是的。他们正处于一场大规模政变之中，他们说，好吧，等等，我不想错过那个，所以他去了剧院。当他出来时，他听说勒佩勒蒂埃区（Le Peletier），也就是巴黎市中心的一个区，已经起义了。所以这些区是那种
of local government kind of areas this has been brewing for a long time there's been a lot of discontent they declare their defiance of the sort of central authority and they call on the other sections to rise up and join them that evening the national assembly send a guy called general menu to go and suppress this revolt menu leads his troops into the very narrow streets of le politier and he basically, we're going to get surrounded and trapped. This isn't going to work at all. And actually, what way is the embodiment of the revolution. Exactly. I mean, it has been since 1789. Yeah.
地方政府区域，这种情况已经酝酿了很长时间，一直有很多不满，他们宣布反抗中央权威，并呼吁其他区起来加入他们。那天晚上，国民议会派了一个叫梅努将军的人去镇压这场起义。梅努带着他的部队进入了勒佩勒蒂埃狭窄的街道，他基本上——我们会被包围和困住。这根本行不通。而且实际上，什么是革命的化身。没错。我的意思是，自1789年以来一直如此。是的。
Whereas Napoleon has no such cause at all, which presumably is why Barras has fixed on him. I mean, it's not just his military ability, his command of artillery, but presumably there's also a kind of, he's recognised a- Stealiness? But not merely a stealiness, but an ideological attitude towards what Napoleon presumably would cast as rabbles. Yeah, I think there's that. Do you think, Tom, that his Corsican-ness might be a thing here? That he perhaps doesn't feel the sentimental attachment to the Paris mob that other metropolitan Frenchmen might think?
而拿破仑根本没有这样的事业，这大概就是为什么巴拉斯选中了他。我的意思是，这不仅仅是因为他的军事能力、他对炮兵的指挥，大概还有一种——他识别出了一种……冷酷？但不仅仅是冷酷，还有一种对拿破仑大概会称之为暴民的人群的意识形态态度。是的，我想有这一点。汤姆，你认为他的科西嘉人身份在这里可能是一个因素吗？他可能对巴黎暴民没有其他大都市法国人可能有的那种情感依恋？
Yeah, I'm sure that's true. And he's used to mobs on the streets of Ajaccio, isn't he? Trying to lynch him. So probably he kind of thinks, you know, I'd love to get my own back on a mob one day. But this is also, I mean, it is also, you know, we described how he sees the mobs rampaging through the Tuileries. Yeah.
是的，我肯定那是真的。他习惯了阿雅克肖街头的暴民，不是吗？试图对他动私刑。所以他可能觉得，你知道，我有一天很想对暴民进行报复。但这同时也是，我的意思是，这也是，你知道，我们描述过他是如何看到暴民在杜伊勒里宫横冲直撞的。是的。
He despises it. He does. He thinks it needs to be tamed. So there are two different versions of what happens next. There's Napoleon's version, which is that he goes to the convention. Everybody's in a terrible panic. They're debating different generals. He hears them mention his name.
他鄙视它。他确实如此。他认为它需要被驯服。所以关于接下来发生的事情有两个不同的版本。一个是拿破仑的版本，即他去了国民公会。每个人都陷入了极度的恐慌。他们正在讨论不同的将军。他听到他们提到了他的名字。
He has a think about it, and he says, I will do it as long as you give me total authority to do whatever is necessary. So very kind of Man of Destiny stuff. The other version is Barrasas's version which i think sounds slightly more plausible which is that baras who is far better known than than napoleon says to his friends on the committee of public safety i have the man you need a little corsican officer who won't be squeamish now you can see why napoleon wouldn't want that story told because it's very demeaning to him it does sound slightly more plausible doesn't it so the next morning on the 5th of october when paris awakes
他考虑了一下，说，只要你们给我采取必要行动的全部权力，我就去做。非常有那种“命运之子”的感觉。另一个版本是巴拉斯的版本，我觉得听起来稍微可信一点，那就是比拿破仑出名得多的巴拉斯对他在公安委员会的朋友们说，我找到了你们需要的人，一个不会心慈手软的小科西嘉军官。现在你可以看出为什么拿破仑不想让那个故事流传，因为它对他来说非常贬低。这听起来确实稍微可信一点，不是吗？所以第二天早上，10月5日，当巴黎醒来时
they discover that napoleon as always full of energy full of kind of that work ethic that drive he has already secured loads of guns and he has positioned them around the sort of institutions of government at the Tuileries Palace, on the bridges, at the Place de la Concorde and so on and so forth. He has mustered about 5,000 men, but they are outnumbered, I think, four to one by the mob and the National Guardsmen who have joined the mob. And I guess in Ridley Scott's film, what'll probably do I'm anticipating is they'll show Napoleon firing on the mob as they advance but that actually isn't what happens
他们发现拿破仑一如既往地充满活力，充满那种他所拥有的职业道德和干劲，他已经搞到了大量的枪支，并将它们部署在杜伊勒里宫、桥梁、协和广场等政府机构周围。他召集了大约5000人，但我认为他们的人数比暴民和加入暴民的国民警卫队少四倍。我想在雷德利·斯科特的电影里，我预料他们会展示拿破仑在暴民前进时向他们开火，但那实际上并不是发生的事情。
they then stand around for about the next 12 hours just sort of shuffling their feet and waiting and waiting so when does the whiff of grapeshot happen
他们随后站了大约12个小时，只是在那儿挪动脚步，等待着，等待着。那么“葡萄弹的阵风”是什么时候发生的呢？
it doesn't happen until the late afternoon so it starts raining a lot of people go home that is always the case with kind of mobs coups yeah it's like the
直到傍晚才发生。所以开始下雨了，很多人回家了。暴民政变总是这样。是的，就像
Chartists isn't it? Yeah. As soon as it starts raining, people just think, oh, sod this, I'm going home. I'm not getting wet. It's like cricket. Yeah, it's like cricket. Mob violence and cricket are very, very similar. Yeah.
宪章运动一样，不是吗？是的。一旦开始下雨，人们就想，哦，去他的，我回家了。我可不想淋湿。就像板球一样。是的，就像板球。暴民暴力和板球非常非常相似。是的。
And then Napoleon just says, okay, go for it. And he says, let's show them that we mean business. His cannons open fire and they're using grapes shot, which I'd never really understood. I'd always thought that the whiff of grape shot sounded so trivial that they shot in the air and they shot buckshot or something. But no, it's pretty brutal, isn't it? Because what they do is they've got hundreds of musket balls. They're packing them into this case,
然后拿破仑只是说，好吧，开始吧。他说，让我们向他们展示我们是认真的。他的大炮开火了，他们使用的是葡萄弹，我以前从未真正理解过。我一直以为“葡萄弹的阵风”听起来太微不足道了，以为他们是向空中射击，或者射的是鸟弹之类的。但不是，这相当残酷，不是吗？因为他们做的是，他们有数百颗火枪弹。他们把它们装进这个弹壳里，
this sort of metal cylinder or something, and they shoot them out of the cannon. And as it comes out of the cannon... It just goes everywhere. Yeah. The case explodes. The metal balls fly. Do you see this, how quickly they go? It's kind of like shrapnel.
这种金属圆筒之类的东西，然后从大炮里射出去。当它从大炮里出来时……它到处乱飞。是的。弹壳爆炸了。金属球飞溅。你看到了吗，它们飞得有多快？这有点像弹片。
They go about 2,000 feet per second. That speed. You wouldn't want to be in the middle of that, would you? And they can go up to 600 yards. But you know what Napoleon said of the rabble, Dominic? He said it must be persuaded by terror. He puts those words into action. I don't want to say he did it and he was right to do it, but he did it and it
它们以每秒约2000英尺的速度飞行。那个速度。你可不想身处其中，对吧？它们可以飞到600码远。但你知道拿破仑是怎么评价暴民的吗，多米尼克？他说它必须被恐怖所说服。他把这些话付诸行动。我不想说他做了这件事而且他是对的，但他确实做了，而且
worked. I mean, it could not have worked more successfully. And effectively, this is what ends the role that the mob has been playing in the politics of France for about 30 years, doesn't it? Yeah, totally. How many people are killed? We don't know. Hundreds. Some people might say even 1,000. But the net result of it is that the new regime completely wins. The mob is dispelled. The royalist uprising disappears. Barras is left in full charge of the city.
奏效了。我的意思是，它不可能更成功了。实际上，这结束了暴民在法国政治中扮演了大约30年的角色，不是吗？是的，完全如此。有多少人被杀？我们不知道。数百人。有些人甚至可能会说1000人。但最终的结果是，新政权完全获胜。暴民被驱散了。保皇党起义消失了。巴拉斯留下来完全掌控了这座城市。
He has Napoleon appointed as the commander of the army of the interior as his reward. So he is now effectively the military governor of Paris. And Napoleon seizes that opportunity. He closes down some of the clubs. He reforms the National Guard. He gets new positions for all of his cronies. So Junot. And his family.
作为奖励，他任命拿破仑为内政军司令。所以他现在实际上是巴黎的军事总督。拿破仑抓住了这个机会。他关闭了一些俱乐部。他改组了国民警卫队。他为他所有的亲信安排了新职位。比如朱诺。还有他的家人。
Marmont. And his family. Exactly. Yeah, his family. So that's, again, very Corsican, isn't it? Clans, clan loyalties, all that kind of thing. And he also, no, it's not just that he does all that, but he also starts to now turn himself into a celebrity.
马尔蒙。还有他的家人。没错。是的，他的家人。所以这又非常科西嘉，不是吗？氏族，氏族忠诚，所有那类事情。而且他还，不，不仅仅是他做了所有这些，他还开始把自己变成一个名人。
He is the man that won the day, and he starts riding around the city with his officers. They have enormous moustaches. He doesn't have an enormous moustache, but they do. They're wearing massive hats, big boots, and they're kind of a very impressive spectacle. And they're making it clear. They're very young. They're in their twenties. And they're making it clear to everybody in Paris, we are the new generation. We're in charge. Who are in charge now. Yeah. We're the new masters. Now, one of the other things that he
他是赢得胜利的人，他开始带着他的军官们在城市里骑马。他们留着巨大的胡子。他没有巨大的胡子，但他们有。他们戴着巨大的帽子，穿着大靴子，他们是一种非常令人印象深刻的景象。他们正在表明立场。他们非常年轻。他们才二十多岁。他们向巴黎的所有人表明，我们是新一代。我们掌权。谁现在掌权。是的。我们是新的主人。现在，他做的另一件事是
does is he says he's going to confiscate all privately held arms. And he says to people, if you are found with private weapons, they will be taken away from you. And again, I mean, this is the key thing, isn't it? Over the previous years, the inability of anyone to exercise a monopoly of violence is what has made politics so chaotic and brutal. But from this point on, effectively, there is a monopoly of violence. Yeah. And people, do you think they crave order by this time? Six years of chaos? I think so.
他说他要没收所有私人持有的武器。他对人们说，如果发现你们持有私人武器，它们将被没收。再说一次，我的意思是，这是关键所在，不是吗？在过去的几年里，任何人都没有能力行使暴力垄断，这使得政治变得如此混乱和残酷。但从这一点开始，实际上，存在着一种暴力垄断。是的。你认为人们此时渴望秩序吗？六年的混乱？我想是的。
I think most people do. And lots of people want a quiet life and they think, great, finally, he's sorting it out. Now, one of the people he wants to confiscate arms from is this family where a 14-year-old boy supposedly comes to his headquarters and says, can I please keep my father's sword? Because my father was a general and he was guillotined in the terror and i would love to keep his sword and bone apart what a soft-hearted man he is he says course you young whippersnapper course my boy ruffles his hair and then well it depends which story you believe maybe he goes to the boy's house to pay his respects to the boy's mother, to the widow himself.
我想大多数人都是这样。很多人想要平静的生活，他们想，太好了，终于，他在解决问题了。现在，他想要没收武器的对象之一是这个家庭，一个14岁的男孩据称来到他的总部说，我能保留我父亲的剑吗？因为我父亲是一位将军，他在恐怖时期被送上了断头台，我很想保留他的剑。波拿巴，多么心软的人啊，他说，当然可以，你这个年轻的小家伙，当然可以，我的孩子。揉了揉他的头发，然后，嗯，这取决于你相信哪个故事，也许他去了那个男孩的家，亲自向男孩的母亲，那位遗孀表示敬意。
Maybe she comes to visit him, or maybe Tom has already met her at loads of parties around the city, and this story is completely invented and not true. Because who is the woman, Dominic? She is Marie-Joseph Rose de Beauharnais, born Tasha, but better known to us all as Josephine. At last. And Josephine is an extraordinary character. So her family owned a plantation in Martinique and had married her off.
也许她来拜访他，或者也许汤姆已经在城里的很多聚会上见过她，而这个故事完全是编造的，不是真的。因为那个女人是谁，多米尼克？她是玛丽-约瑟芬·罗斯·德·博阿尔内，原名塔舍，但我们大家都更熟悉她叫约瑟芬。终于。约瑟芬是一个非凡的人物。她的家族在马提尼克岛拥有一个种植园，并把她嫁了出去。
She spends her childhood there, doesn't she? Exactly, yes. And so a taste for sugarcane, which doesn help with her her dentistry her teeth no so she's lost all her teeth hasn't she because of she's eaten far too much sugar which is never an attractive thing i think but she she's very good at disguising it isn't she um she can kind of smiles and keeps her her lips together she does and she's had a very strange life up to this point. She had been married off to this guy called Alexandre de Beauharnais, who was just a terrible person. He was unfaithful. He was abusive. He was jealous. When the revolution happened, he was put in charge
她在那里度过了童年，不是吗？没错，是的。所以对甘蔗的偏爱，这对她的牙科、她的牙齿没有帮助，嗯，所以她所有的牙齿都掉了，不是吗？因为她吃了太多的糖，这从来都不是一件吸引人的事情，我想，但她非常擅长掩饰，不是吗？嗯，她可以那种微笑并保持嘴唇闭合。她确实如此，而且到目前为止她过着非常奇怪的生活。她曾被嫁给一个叫亚历山大·德·博阿尔内的家伙，他简直是个糟糕透顶的人。他不忠。他虐待人。他嫉妒。当革命发生时，他被任命为
of the army of the Rhine and he was totally inept. He lost the fortress at Mance and was accused of treason and executed. And she was thrown into the same prison that he was, a prison called Les Carmes. He had an affair in this prison with some other general's widow, and she had an affair with General Lazar Osh, who was the guy who ends up commanding the army in the Vendée. And she's having that affair in the prison. And this is quite common, isn't it? Totally, yeah. Because if you're pregnant, you can't be guillotined.
莱茵军团的指挥官，但他完全无能。他丢掉了曼斯要塞，被指控叛国并被处决。她被扔进了他所在的同一个监狱，一个叫卡尔姆的监狱。他在这个监狱里和另一个将军的遗孀有染，而她和拉扎尔·奥什将军有染，那个最终在旺代指挥军队的家伙。她在监狱里和那个人有染。这很常见，不是吗？完全是，是的。因为如果你怀孕了，你就不能被送上断头台。
Exactly. So lots of female prisoners are having sex with jailers and everybody to try and get pregnant. The descriptions by Napoleon's biographers of the prison are actually terrifying. So apparently the walls are still smeared with blood from the massacres in September 1792 of all these priests and stuff. But people are copulating in all different parts of the prison, partly because of this thing of trying to escape if you're a pregnant woman, but also this sort of last desperate act of hedonism before the blade comes down. As Roberts says, he thinks she ended up suffering from post-traumatic stress disorder,
没错。所以很多女囚犯都在和狱卒以及所有人发生性关系，试图怀孕。拿破仑的传记作者对监狱的描述实际上非常可怕。所以显然墙上还沾着1792年9月大屠杀中所有这些神职人员等的血迹。但人们在监狱的各个角落交配，部分是因为这种试图通过怀孕来逃脱的念头，但也因为这是一种在刀刃落下之前最后的绝望享乐行为。正如罗伯茨所说，他认为她最终患上了创伤后应激障碍，
Josephine, because of her experiences in the prison. Anyway, she gets out. She carries on with General Osh still. She also becomes the mistress of Paul Barras. Now, Barras was quite ungallant about her. He said she was precociously decrepit, which is a harsh thing. She's old, isn't she? I mean, by the standards of successful courtesans.
约瑟芬，因为她在监狱里的经历。无论如何，她出狱了。她仍然和奥什将军保持关系。她也成了保罗·巴拉斯的情妇。现在，巴拉斯对她很不客气。他说她“早衰”，这话说得很重。她老了，不是吗？我的意思是，按照成功交际花的标准。
She's what, 35 or something? She's 32. 32. She's not that old. But considering the role that she is playing, I mean, she doesn't have any money, does she? No. She's lost all her money.
她多少岁，35岁左右？她32岁。32岁。她没那么老。但考虑到她所扮演的角色，我的意思是，她没有任何钱，不是吗？没有。她失去了所有的钱。
So she's dependent on rich and powerful men. Yeah. A bit like Emma Hamilton. Same thing. But what Josephine, she doesn't have teeth. That's true. And Barras says she's decrepit, and you very ungallantly say she no longer has her youth.
所以她依赖于富有和有权势的男人。是的。有点像艾玛·汉密尔顿。一样的事情。但约瑟芬，她没有牙齿。那是真的。巴拉斯说她早衰，而你很不客气地说她不再年轻了。
But what she has tom is what barras himself calls the most refined the most perfected artistry ever practiced by the courtesans of ancient greece or paris in the exercise of their profession so she's a very accomplished performer and napoleon at this stage is not it would be fair to say no napoleon not at all he's gauche he's inexperienced with women, shifty, awkward. I mean, he's certainly never done something that she does, that Andrew Roberts discusses, says he doesn't know what it is, which is called the zigzags. Yes.
但汤姆，她拥有的是巴拉斯本人所说的“古希腊或巴黎交际花在其职业生涯中实践过的最精致、最完美的艺术”。所以她是一个非常有成就的表演者，而拿破仑在这个阶段，公平地说，并不是。不，拿破仑根本不是。他笨拙，对女性缺乏经验，鬼鬼祟祟，尴尬。我的意思是，他肯定从未做过她做的那种事，安德鲁·罗伯茨讨论过，说他不知道那是什么，被称为“之字形”。是的。
Do you know what the zigzags are, Tom? Well, I don't because nobody does. Nobody knows. Nobody knows, but it absolutely wins Napoleon's heart, doesn't it? It does. He becomes obsessed by her. And an example of that obsession is the kind of lurid tones of the love letter that I read out at the head of the show.
你知道什么是“之字形”吗，汤姆？嗯，我不知道，因为没人知道。没人知道。没人知道，但这绝对赢得了拿破仑的心，不是吗？确实。他开始对她着迷。那种迷恋的一个例子就是我在节目开头读到的那封情书的煽情语调。
Yeah. And I mean, his letters to her are astonishing. I mean, very explicit. We talked about the whiff of grapeshot, but he is very keen on her not washing. Yes. So that's something he really likes. So that's another whiff. Yeah.
是的。我的意思是，他写给她的信令人震惊。我的意思是，非常露骨。我们谈到了“葡萄弹的阵风”，但他非常希望她不要洗澡。是的。所以这是他非常喜欢的一点。所以那是另一阵风。是的。
And he calls her private parts, Baron de Kepa. Yeah. Nobody knows why. Something to do with the zigzags, is it? So zigzags, Baron de Kepa, no washing, it's all happening. But from the start,
他称她的私处为“巴隆·德·凯帕”。是的。没人知道为什么。和“之字形”有关吗？所以“之字形”、“巴隆·德·凯帕”、不洗澡，这一切都在发生。但从一开始，
she's not keen on him. She calls him a puss in boots. She says he comes from a family of beggars. She's not keen on him she calls him a puss in boots she says he comes from a family of beggars she's not that interested really she would much rather married general osh i think or barras well barras basically a lot of people say he was trying to get rid of an unwanted mistress so again it's like emma hamilton who gets dumped by hamilton's nephew on him that's right yeah but also there's an element with barras as some biographers say the thing with Barras is he wants to get rid of Josephine. She's just a pain and he's sick of her. He also wants to distract. He wants to both bind Napoleon to him and also
她就不喜欢他。她叫他“穿靴子的猫”。她说他来自一个乞丐家庭。她不喜欢他，她叫他“穿靴子的猫”，她说他来自一个乞丐家庭。她真的没那么感兴趣，她宁愿嫁给奥什将军，我想，或者巴拉斯。好吧，巴拉斯基本上，很多人说他是在试图摆脱一个不想要的情妇，所以这又像艾玛·汉密尔顿，被汉密尔顿的侄子甩给了他，没错，是的。但巴拉斯也有一个因素，正如一些传记作者所说，巴拉斯的问题是他想摆脱约瑟芬。她只是个麻烦，他厌倦了她。他也想分散注意力。他既想把拿破仑绑在自己身边，也想
kind of Napoleon is being really difficult and annoying because he's always writing plans for invasions and demanding meetings and kind of, you know, working too much. So deploy the zigzags. Yeah. So Varys thinks deploy the zigzags, get him distracted. It's just being a pain. And as you say, he is totally and utterly smitten. To be fair, this is the one point in the whole series where I think he comes out quite well
拿破仑表现得非常困难和烦人，因为他总是写入侵计划，要求开会，而且，你知道，工作太努力了。所以部署“之字形”。是的。所以巴拉斯想，部署“之字形”，让他分心。他只是个麻烦。正如你所说，他完全被迷住了。公平地说，这是整个系列中我认为他表现得相当好的一点，
because I was impressed to read that he's very nice to her children so he goes to visit they're 14 and 12 Eugène and Hortense what about the young boy who's come for the sword well he's he's Eugène he's Eugène yeah and um Napoleon tells him ghost stories and plays with him yeah that is nice so we haven't seen that side of him no that is nice yeah I imagine he's playing wooden soldiers though. Oh, undoubtedly. This is an attack on the English. Let's, you know, I'll be the French again, that kind of thing. But meanwhile, Dominic, while he is playing wooden soldiers with Josephine's children,
因为我印象深刻地读到他对她的孩子们非常好，所以他去拜访了14岁和12岁的欧仁和奥尔唐斯。那个为剑而来的小男孩呢？嗯，他是欧仁，他是欧仁。是的，嗯，拿破仑给他讲鬼故事，和他一起玩。是的，那很好，所以我们还没见过他那一面。不，那很好。是的，我想象他在玩木头士兵。哦，毫无疑问。这是对英国人的攻击。让我们，你知道，我再当一次法国人，那种事情。但与此同时，多米尼克，当他和约瑟芬的孩子们玩木头士兵时，
I mean, he is seriously looking to have a crack at the Italians, isn't he? He is. So France is great antagonist. It was not just Britain. It's also Austria. Of course, Marion Sarnet was Austrian. Austria is the great power in Central Europe. And Napoleon has always thought, we can knock out Austria if we make a two-pronged attack. One army goes through Germany, and the other, led by me, will go through Italy, through
我的意思是，他确实在认真考虑去教训一下意大利人，不是吗？是的。所以法国是伟大的对手。不仅仅是英国。还有奥地利。当然，玛丽·安托瓦内特是奥地利人。奥地利是中欧的强国。拿破仑一直认为，如果我们进行两面夹击，我们可以击垮奥地利。一支军队穿过德国，另一支由我领导，将穿过意大利，穿过
the Tyrol, and up towards Vienna. The soft underbelly, I believe is the phrase. Only a fool would describe that as a soft underbelly, because that's the white war from World War I. But you're right. Napoleon thinks it's a soft underbelly. I'm not calling you a fool, Tom. I'm calling Napoleon a fool if he thinks that's a soft underbelly. Anyway. I'm glad that's been made clear. Yeah, I would never do that to you. Not after that reading like that to start the episode. I mean, that was genius. So the other commanders say, this is a very bad idea.
蒂罗尔，向维也纳进军。“软腹部”，我相信是这个词。只有傻瓜才会把它描述为软腹部，因为那是第一次世界大战的白战。但你是对的。拿破仑认为那是软腹部。我不是在叫你傻瓜，汤姆。如果拿破仑认为那是软腹部，我是在叫拿破仑傻瓜。无论如何。我很高兴这一点已经说清楚了。是的，我永远不会那样对你。在节目开始时那样读了之后。我的意思是，那是天才。所以其他指挥官说，这是一个非常糟糕的主意。
Don't do it. But Napoleon manages to persuade everybody that it's a great plan and that he is the man to lead it. And before leaving, he decides, first of all, he reads everything that he can about Italy, maps, books. He shuts himself for a whole week in his office reading up on it. But also he decides to make an honest woman of Josephine, which is lovely. And she's actually very ambivalent about getting married, isn't she?
别做。但拿破仑设法说服了所有人，这是一个伟大的计划，他是领导它的人。在离开之前，他决定，首先，他阅读了所有他能找到的关于意大利的资料，地图，书籍。他在办公室里把自己关了一个星期，阅读相关资料。但他也决定让约瑟芬成为一个正经的女人，这很可爱。而且她实际上对结婚非常矛盾，不是吗？
She doesn't really want to do it. Yeah. But. Signs up to it. Yeah. And very romantically, he forgets about it, doesn't he? Well, he's distracted by his war plans. Yeah.
她并不真的想这样做。是的。但还是签了字。是的。而且非常浪漫的是，他忘记了这件事，不是吗？嗯，他被他的战争计划分散了注意力。是的。
And then he turns up two hours late, doesn't he? He does. And she is wearing a revolutionary sash. So, tricolour. That's nice. Looking very gorgeous. And at the wedding, they both lie about their age. So, Napoleon says he's older and Josephine says she's younger.
然后他迟到了两个小时，不是吗？他确实迟到了。而她穿着一条革命腰带。所以，三色旗。那很好。看起来非常华丽。在婚礼上，他们都谎报了年龄。所以，拿破仑说他更老，而约瑟芬说她更年轻。
Yeah. Yeah. So, they have the same age. And also, she's been waiting for two hours. The guy who was meant to conduct the wedding ceremony has got sick of waiting and has gone home to bed. So they never actually get married, do they, legally? Yeah, because the guy who steps in is not actually legally equipped to do that.
是的。是的。所以，他们年龄一样。而且，她已经等了两个小时。那个本应主持婚礼的人已经等得不耐烦，回家睡觉去了。所以他们实际上从未真正结婚，不是吗，在法律上？是的，因为那个介入的人实际上在法律上没有资格那样做。
So it's invalid. Napoleon gives her a wedding gift, a medallion with the words, to destiny on it. And he is now, I mean, he is now in a position to live up to this kind of melodrama. Yes. From this point on, when Napoleon says, to destiny, it's not inherently ridiculous.
所以它是无效的。拿破仑给了她一份结婚礼物，一个刻有“致命运”字样的奖章。而他现在，我的意思是，他现在处于能够实现这种情节剧的地位。是的。从这一点开始，当拿破仑说“致命运”时，它并不是天生荒谬的。
No. He is becoming a man of destiny. Although what I did enjoy, Tom, which is inherently ridiculous, is his wedding night. They go back home and Napoleon tries to get into Josephine's bed and her dog won't let him do it.
不。他正在成为命运之子。虽然我确实很喜欢的一点，汤姆，这天生就很荒谬，是他的新婚之夜。他们回到家，拿破仑试图进入约瑟芬的床，而她的狗不让他进去。
No, Fortunet, her pet pug. Yeah, and bites him to stop him getting into her bed. Not tonight. Which probably, yeah. Bone apart. Yeah. This is the thing, the whole not tonight, Josephine. Josephine is really never that keen on him because she's always unfaithful to him, isn't she, later on?
不，福尔图内，她的宠物哈巴狗。是的，咬他以阻止他进入她的床。今晚不行。这可能，是的。波拿巴。是的。这就是那件事，“今晚不行，约瑟芬”。约瑟芬从来没那么喜欢他，因为她后来总是对他不忠，不是吗？
Yeah. And she's hung around with a lot more worldly and impressive, so it would seem, richer and more impressive men than Boney. is the one that David will immortalize with his great painting, showing him as a kind of Hannibal crossing the Alps. And this is the moment, isn't it? Just as he's about to head off to take up the command of the Italian army, that he changes the spelling of his name. It's the perfect moment to end this, Tom, actually, because so much of this week's little series has been about the tension between Corsica and France and also the
是的。而且她和很多看起来更世俗、更令人印象深刻、更富有、更令人印象深刻的男人混在一起，而不是波拿巴。是那个大卫将用他伟大的画作使他永垂不朽，展示他作为一种翻越阿尔卑斯山的汉尼拔。这就是那一刻，不是吗？就在他准备出发去接管意大利军队指挥权时，他改变了他的名字拼写。汤姆，这实际上是结束这一集的完美时刻，因为本周小系列的很多内容都是关于科西嘉和法国之间的紧张关系，以及
sort of ambivalence within Napoleon about who he will be, who he is and who he'll be. And the first time he ever signs his name Bonaparte rather than Buonaparte is the letter that he writes to Josephine after he's left the headquarters of the army of Italy to begin this great enterprise that he has dreamed up. He writes, every instant takes me further away from you, my adorable love. With every instant, I find less and less strength of which to bear being away from you. You are the constant object of all my thoughts. And he signs that bonaparte. So it's as though he's finally pinned his colors to the French mast.
拿破仑内心关于他将成为谁、他是谁以及他将成为谁的矛盾。他第一次签下名字“波拿巴”而不是“布昂纳巴”是在他离开意大利军团总部开始他梦想的这一伟大事业后写给约瑟芬的信中。他写道：“每一刻都让我离你更远，我可爱的爱人。每一刻，我发现承受远离你的力量越来越少。你是所有思想中不变的对象。”他签名为“波拿巴”。所以这就像他终于把自己的立场固定在了法国的桅杆上。
You know, he's no longer the little guy from Corsica, but he is the war hero, the embodiment of France, who's going to carry the flag of the revolution against the reactionary powers. And so that, Dominic, is why, although the accent at the start of this show on one level was inaccurate, in another, it speaks to a profounder truth yeah beautifully judged the truth being that napoleon from this point forward is a frenchman he's a frenchman and you know what people say he's um too young to command the army of italy and he has a wonderful line he says i should be old when i return and we will come back to that won't we maybe not immediately but we will come back to that won't we maybe not immediately
你知道，他不再是那个来自科西嘉的小家伙，而是战争英雄，法国的化身，他将带着革命的旗帜对抗反动势力。所以，多米尼克，这就是为什么，虽然节目开始时的口音在某种程度上是不准确的，但在另一方面，它诉说着一个更深刻的真理。是的，判断得很美，真理就是拿破仑从这一点开始是一个法国人。他是一个法国人，你知道人们怎么说，他太年轻了，不能指挥意大利军队，他有一句精彩的话，他说：“我回来时应该已经老了。”我们会回到这一点，不是吗？也许不是立即，但我们会回到这一点，不是吗？也许不是立即
but we will come back to nevolium we can't just leave him hanging there forever but when we do we've done the french revolution because i think so many interesting things to talk about with the french revolution that we just have skimmed over when we did it on the rest is history all those 50 minutes yeah exactly so next year we'll do a big series on the french revolution all the blood and guts all the idealism all the aspirations and the ideas and the ideology and all the faction fighting and all that sort of stuff and tom i think we should do that on location we should we should go to the city of light so a tryst with destiny oh wait napoleon is napoleon would put it.
但我们会回到拿破仑，我们不能就这样让他永远悬在那里。但当我们这样做时，我们就完成了法国大革命，因为我认为关于法国大革命有太多有趣的事情要谈，我们在“历史的其余部分”中做它时只是略过，那所有的50分钟。是的，完全正确。所以明年我们将做一个关于法国大革命的大系列，所有的血腥和勇气，所有的理想主义，所有的抱负和思想和意识形态，以及所有的派系斗争和所有那类事情。汤姆，我认为我们应该在现场做。我们应该去光之城。所以，与命运的幽会。哦，等等，拿破仑是……拿破仑会这样说。
So thank you very much for listening and à bientôt. Bye-bye. host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以非常感谢你们的收听，再见。拜拜。主持人《娱乐的其余部分》。这是你们每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。